[Musique]
il y a maintenant bien longtemps
la nature nous a créés en nous créant
elle nous a dotés de capacités et grâce
à ses capacités
nous avons su évoluer pour en arriver au
monde tel qu'il est aujourd'hui mais
comment cela est-il possible
et bien grâce aux connaissances acquises
mais aussi à notre capacité de façonner
notre environnement
finalement à servir à nos désirs de
progrès cette nature qui un jour nous a
donné la vie par le passé
nos ancêtres ont appris petit à petit à
connaître et à se servir des plantes à
domestiquer des animaux mais aussi à
utiliser des matériaux pour améliorer
les conditions de vie mais aujourd'hui
je constate que nous irons plus en
harmonie avec notre environnement et
nous commençons d'ailleurs en payer le
prix et de différentes façons mais pour
ma part celle qui me préoccupe le plus
c'est la maladie et pas n'importe
laquelle puisqu'il s'agit du cancer vous
et moi nous le savons tous de nos jours
le cancer nous touche tous de près ou de
loin directement ou indirectement et
cette maladie se fiche éperdument de qui
nous sommes de notre mode de vie de
notre statut social du fait que nous
soyons riches ou pauvres peu importe
elle peut toucher n'importe qui
n'importe où n'importe comment et plus
tristement d'ailleurs les adultes comme
les enfants
pour ma part j'en veux beaucoup à cette
maladie car elle a remporté mon père est
de ce fait je pourrais jamais présenté
nos fils à son grand père ça c'est un
regret énorme pour moi irrattrapable et
dans ma famille beaucoup de personnes
ont aussi été victimes
donc dans mon cas on pourrait lui parler
d'une petite hécatombe mais bon passons
maintenant proche non nous un petit peu
dans l'avenir selon les chiffres de l'
oms l'organisation mondiale de la santé
en 2030
on comptera 20 millions de nouveaux cas
de cancer par an si colossal et d'après
ce que je sais pour travailler dans ce
domaine
ces chiffres sont peut-être sous-estimé
alors comment avons nous pu en arriver
là et je dirais de façon différente qui
s'ajoutant les unes aux autres nous
conduisent à ce déplorable constat notre
mode de vie
tout du moins pour les pays développés
tel que le nôtre est en grande partie
responsable
la progression de cette maladie et je
pourrais citer des exemples la pollution
perturbateurs endocriniens la malbouffe
et pesticides et bien évidemment dans
nos vies le stress des croyez-moi ce
moment je sais de quoi je parle
mais du coup c'est bien beau mais on en
oublie une chose c'est que l'espèce
humaine n'est pas la seule à être
touchée par le cancer
en fait il ya beaucoup d'espèces
animales 1 qui peuvent développer des
cancers et compte tenu de l'impact que
nous générons sur l'environnement il est
fort à parier que le nombre de cas de
cancers touchant les espèces animales
ira lui aussi grandissant ne sera pas
les seuls maintenant ces espèces
qu'elles n'ont pas les moyens dont nous
disposons pour se soigner
encore que vous savez peut-être il
s'avère que certaines espèces animales
sont très très peu sujette aux cancers
très très peu quelle chance et pourquoi
on n'a pas cette chance
ça je ne pourrai pas vous le dire
maintenant l'exemple le plus connu à mon
sens c'est celui des requins c'est en
effet ces animaux contrairement aux
autres il développe vraiment très très
peu la maladie
enfin ça c'était avant
parce qu'entre temps où le savait depuis
la catastrophe nucléaire de fukushima
et depuis cette catastrophe d'un
maintenant quand on se balade dans le
pacifique et qu'on plonge mais on trouve
des requins huit ans non j'exagère un
petit peu sont pas vraiment du temps
mais on voit que ces animaux ils se
mettent à développer des tumeurs et ça
c'est pas tout à fait normal ça me fait
penser que finalement on n'est plus très
loin du scénario de godzilla à une
époque ça nous faisait marrer mais
maintenant c'est plus vraiment le cas et
c'est là aussi un parfait mais un triste
exemple de l'impact que nous avons sur
l'environnement et sur les espèces en
fait avec lesquels nous le partageons et
c'est dommage
c'est vraiment dommage parce que
finalement quand vous y réfléchissez
bien la nature a tout à nous offrir
et quelque part elle le fait déjà si
vous prenez une minute et vous regardez
autour de vous dans la pièce fois vous
apercevoir que tout ce que vous voyez a
été façonné à partir de matériaux qui un
jour ont été arrachés à la nature
mais malgré tout je pense que
l'ignorance de notre espèce pourtant si
intelligente par rapport à toutes les
autres
c'est ce qu'on pense elles nous font du
droit dans le mur maintenant repartons
un petit peu dans le passé et
rappelez-vous léonard de vinci homme
brillant remarquable qui a marqué
l'histoire pour l'offre qui nous a
laissé mon point de vue sa principale
qualité à léonard de vinci
c'était sa capacité à observer et à
contempler son environnement et une eau
de ses qualités complémentaires de
celles ci c'était en fait sa capacité à
faire des déductions à partir des
observations qui faisait dans la nature
rappelez vous il a créé des machines
volantes qui s'inspirera directement de
ce qu'il avait vu en observant les
oiseaux ou encore dans le magnifique
dessin de l'hélicoptère qui nous a fait
des siècles avant que la première
machine ne décolle du sol à mon sens
c'est peut-être l'exemple le plus connu
de gens qui sont inspirées de la nature
mais finalement on peut s'apercevoir que
combien d'invention découle directement
de la nature derrière nabot énormément
beaucoup plus qu'on imagine j'espère
qu'à l'avenir il y en a encore beaucoup
d'autres
mais maintenant revenons un petit peu à
nos moutons le cancer et la nature la
nature et le cancer comme vous préférez
le cancer c'est une maladie grave pour
laquelle comme je vous l'aï dit
certaines espèces animales sont
largement mieux lotis que d'autres et si
elles développent point de cancer c'est
finalement peut-être que la nature a
trouvé des solutions pour lutter contre
la maladie ou tudou - ou tout du moins
pardon elle à trouver des mécanismes
pour éviter qu'elles n'apparaissent je
vous avez cité les requins les requins
ce n'est pas un cas isolé
malheureusement ces magnifiques animaux
qui sont d'une importance primordiale
pour les mers et les océans bas ils sont
menacés
et malheureusement c'est pas les seuls à
être touchés
maintenant je vais vous parler un petit
peu des coraux je connais bien
ces coraux c'est quoi ces des animaux
peu connu et qui ont malgré leur toute
petite taille pour certaines espèces ont
réussi à bâtir des structures
faramineuses tels que la grande barrière
de corail en australie des structures
qu'on peut quand même voir depuis
l'espace l'être humain est très
longtemps avant de pouvoir en faire
autant
je dirais que c'est phénoménal de
construire des choses aussi grande pour
des animaux city mais avant d'entrer
dans le détail combien d'entre vous
pensent savoir ce qui est vraiment un
corey lever la main si vous pensez
savoir ce que c'est
et ouais ça fait pas grand monde eh bien
les coraux d'abord ce soir ce sont des
animaux ces animaux ils sont apparus sur
terre il ya des centaines de millions
d'années
approximativement 350 millions d'années
et ce qui est magnifique c'est qu'à
chaque fois ils ont su s'adapter
survivent à toutes les crises majeures
de l'évolution la dernière en date que
tout le monde connaisse et jurassic park
c'est un des dinosaures ont disparu de
la terre est bien à ce moment là les
coraux ben ali sont adaptés ils ont
survécu et ils ont encore une fois
colonisés leur environnement en fait ces
animaux ils sont incroyables à plein
d'égards et moi une fascine depuis
vraiment très très longtemps
saviez vous que ces animaux qui vivent
en symbiose avec des algues à
l'intérieur même de leur cellule ne
connaissent pas la sénescence là vous
allez venir mais qu'est ce que c'est la
sénescence et balaci naissance c'est le
fameux vieillissement cellulaire
c'est ce qui fait que tous les
organismes vivants finissent un jour ou
l'autre par péricliter et disparaître
sauf le corail magnifique on a une
source de jouvence j'ai envie de dire
adieu rider arthrose n'est tranquille me
des coraux et c'est par elle sur le
prodige dont ils sont capables
ils ont également des facultés de
régénération qui sont hors normes
voulait couper
vous en avez deux identiques qui
régénère ils sont meilleurs que nous
parce que non seulement ils s'autorisent
d'armes et en plus il ya pas de
cicatrice et ça je crois qu'il ya plein
de personnes qui aimeraient pouvoir en
dire autant
moi compris et c'est pas tous les
animaux c'est aussi des animaux qui sont
cécile et cécile c'est un terme barbare
de biologistes et qu'est ce que ça veut
dire là encore ça veut dire qu'ils sont
des animaux qui vivent fixer un endroit
peuvent pas bouger il se met là ils
grandissent là il pousse la et bouge pas
mais dans ce cas là à me direz vous
comment se défendre quand on peut pas
bouger
la réponse finalement là c'est sympa
c'est grâce à la chimie et pas n'importe
laquelle
parce que ils ont peaufiné ses
mécanismes de défense sur des millions
d'années
autant vous dire que ces mécanismes sont
vraiment plutôt aboutie
donc outre ses capacités incroyables les
coraux sont aussi des constructeurs
comme je voulais lui des bâtisseurs les
structures qu'ils construisent et fameux
récifs coralliens en fait ça représente
qu'une toute petite superficie dans les
mers et les océans
mais cette superficie aussi petite soit
elle est bien selon les estimations des
biologistes elle abrite quand même 80 %
de la biodiversité ce qui est énorme
80 % de la biodiversité marine mais bon
si les chiffres sont à prendre avec
réserve un parce qu'on a encore beaucoup
de choses à découvrir et quand on pourra
explorer du fond des océans peut-être
que on pourra largement augmenter le
nombre d'espèces qu'on connaît en tout
cas dans la mer et bien malheureusement
les coraux eux aussi sont menacés et là
j'ai envie de vous dire que c'est pas
top du tout et pourquoi
récemment les scientifiques nous ont
alarmé sur le fait que à cause du
réchauffement des eaux à 90% la grande
barrière de corail avait blanchi c'est
pas terrible vraiment pas terrifier
après tout cas pas un super bilan et
plus récemment encore les scientifiques
toujours les mêmes ils nous ont expliqué
que maintenant tout même des nano
particules de plastique dans les
cellules des coraux c'est pour vous dire
jusqu'où ça peut aller
pour moi c'est une cata je vous
expliquer pourquoi
parce que malgré ses facultés
exceptionnelles d'adaptation et de
survie maintenant à l'échelle et la
vitesse où on va ils pourront pu
résister bien longtemps
enfin peut-être pas tous donc comme vous
le voyez ça fait des années que je suis
passionné par la vie marine alors c'est
la raison pour laquelle un moment donné
dans mes études j'ai bifurqué jolie
souriante et vert l'aquaculture et dans
l'aquaculture
je me suis spécialisé sur l'élevage des
coraux pourquoi et bien parce qu'à force
de les observer ces animaux ce soit sur
un récif corallien ou dans les aquariums
j'ai pu constater les extraordinaires
interactions chimiques qu'il y ait entre
ces espèces de coraux et ça m'a donné
envie de creuser et d'explorer un
potentiel faramineux c'est aussi la
raison pour laquelle je me suis lancée
il ya maintenant six ans dans la
création d'une entreprise dans une
entreprise
d'un genre un peu particulier j'ai créé
avec l'aide de mon sens un ancien
professeur de biologie à l'université
une société de biotech dont la vocation
est de cultiver des coraux afin de les
étudier d'en extraire des molécules
d'intérêt en santé humaine
à mes yeux en fait les récifs coralliens
les coraux sont nouvelles pharmacopée
qui n'a absolument rien à envier à ce
qu'on a déjà pu trouver par exemple dans
la canopée amazonienne en fait c'est
sans commune mesure
je pense qu'on a des milliers voire des
millions de fois plus de molécules à
trouver dans cet environnement que dans
les plantes comme on l'a déjà fait il
s'avère que les travaux qu'on a mené
avec ma société
ils nous ont permis d'identifier une
nouvelle espèce de corail là pour le
coup c'est pas un corail bâtisseurs
c'est encore ayew
il paye pas de mine mais en fait la
particularité de ce corps ice et qui
concentre une molécule qui est connu
depuis longtemps que s'appelle la
palytoxine molécules qui est connu
depuis les années 70 voyez ce n'est pas
tout jeune mais il s'avère que c'est une
des toxines les plus puissantes du monde
et sur les tests qu'on a réalisé il
s'avère que cette toxine est belle et
efficace sur tous les cancers que nous
avons testés au final si je devais faire
les comptes pour être précis je pourrais
vous dire que cette molécule
elle fonctionne sur quarante deux types
de cancer différents pas trop mal
mais bon le plus génial c'est qu'en fait
cette molécule bas et fonctionne sur
beaucoup de cancers et qu'on fonctionne
sur des cancers résistants les cancers
qui deviennent résistants aux thérapies
actuelles et ce qui est encore mieux
c'est qu'elle fonctionne aussi sur des
cancers pour lesquels il a absolument
rien il n'y a pas de thérapie proposée
aux patients donc ça donne un espoir
formidable et aussi un poids de
responsabilité des fois enfin vous est
en fait la particularité de cette
molécule qui a une toxine on va me dire
c'est une toxine comment on peut soigner
avec c'est une question de dose parce
que au d'ozon l'utilisent pour soigner
le cancer
cette molécule qu'est ce qui est fait
elle va rétablir l'apoptose la joie vos
têtes vie direct ici apoptose encore en
termes de scientifiques à deux balles et
ben l'apoptose en fait c'est tout
simplement ce qu'on appelle la mort
cellulaire programmée
c'est un mécanisme qui est inhérent à
toutes les cellules du corps humain à
l'exception de quelques populations de
cellules dont certaines que vous
connaissez et qui s'appelle les cellules
souches et bien habituellement les
cellules cancéreuses et prennent ce
mécanisme l'apoptose elle le met en
sommeil
une fois qu'elles ont fait ça ou penhars
et la fête je peut proliférer de façon
anarchique faire n'importe quoi on va
dire l'organisme une fois que j'ai fait
ça je tu organises lemay s'est vite
terminée
et ben voilà on a trouvé cette molécule
est donc maintenant qu'est ce qu'on fait
dans la teste et on atteste pourquoi pas
tout simplement pour valider son
utilisation en tant que futurs
médicaments anticancéreux donc récemment
nous avons s'est plaint
d'expérimentation et si tout va bien
d'ici quelques semaines et pour d'autres
expérimentations dans quelques mois on
aura les premiers résultats
croiser les doigts mais en même temps
armez-vous un petit peu de patience le
développement de médicaments c'est long
et ça prend des années mais bon c'est
pas grave on lâchera pas le morceau vous
rassurez vous et comme vous pouvez le
voir finalement j'ai un immense
privilège c'est que j'ai réussi à
joindre ma passion de la mer avec ma
volonté de combattre un truc ce fléau là
qui nous concerne toutes et tous et je
suis convaincu de par mon activité que
dans la mer on va découvrir beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup d'autres molécules et
ces molécules elles seront valorisables
dans le domaine de la santé mais pas que
il ya plein de domaines de technologique
dans lesquelles ces molécules trouveront
des applications et c'est là en fait
qu'on en arrive à un principe qui est
connue qui s'appelle le biomimétisme un
principe qui est cher un scientifique
s'appelle idrissa berkane qui consiste
simplement à observer la nature et s'en
inspirer
sur de la rétro ingénierie pour créer
des nouvelles technologies est justement
plus on a développé des technologies
plus on s'est donné les moyens de
retourner voir ce qui se passe est
d'étudier l'ingéniosité du vivant et
justement cette méthode
cette rétro ingénierie nous permettra
justement de développer des nouvelles
technologies qui nous permettront de
faire progresser encore plus notre
espèce maintenant reste pour faire ça va
bien finir
il faudra bien finir par apprendre à
protéger cette nature qui finalement ne
demande que notre respect pour continuer
à tous nous donner pensez-y parce que je
pense sincèrement que notre survie en
dépend
merci